[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute Zitronen
Brownies die werden ultra saftig es ist
ein sehr einfaches Rezept also Anfänger
geeignet ich habe jetzt hier auch schon
die Zutaten stehen ihr findet alle ganz
genau Mengenangaben unten in der Infobox
und ich starte direkt ich habe jetzt
hier Eier die schlage ich in meine
Schüssel ich nehme eigentlich mal meine
Hand meine Küchenmaschine wollte euch
das ganze mit dem Handrührgerät zeigen
weil das funktioniert auch ihr müsst
auch nicht großartig jetzt viel
aufschlagen oder viel Luft reinschlagen
im Gegenteil Brownies in der eher so
faji und saftig genau zu den Eiern gebe
ich jetzt hier einmal noch Zucker und
immer bei süßen Rezepten was ich gerne
dazu gebe ist eine gute Prise Salz die
unterstreicht noch mal den süßen
Geschmack so und das ganze dann so
ungefähr eine Minute aufschlagen so ein
bisschen miteinander verbinden lassen
und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
so zerlassene Butter und Öl habe ich
auch ganz kurz mit eingerührt und jetzt
geht es an die Zitrone da könnt ihr
jetzt wenn ihr merkt dass sie ein
bisschen fest ist einfach so ein
bisschen auf der Arbeitsfläche hin und
her rollen dann bekommt ihr so ein
bisschen mehr Saft raus und ich finde es
auch mal wichtig zu erwähnen wie groß
eine Zitrone im Rezept ist wenn ihr zum
Beispiel so eine ganz kleine habt dann
habt ihr weniger Zitronengeschmack oder
wenn sie riesengroß ist das ist auf
jeden Fall eine Bio Zitrone da könnt ihr
die Schale mit verwenden und das macht
im Geschmack auch noch mal richtig was
aus falls ihr keine Zitrone da habt es
gibt bei Kaufland in der Backabteilung
auch Bio Zitronenschalen Abrieb habe ich
immer in der Schublade und das könntet
ihr dann auch verwenden so da gebe ich
jetzt einfach mit dieser feinen Reibe
nur die gelbe Schale rein wichtig leute
bitte beachtet dass uns ärgert ihr euch
sagt das Rezept von Kiki schmeckt gar
nicht aber wenn ihr unter der gelben
Schale da kommt der die weiße Schale und
die schmeckt bitter und wenn ihr die
dazu reibt dann ist zu spät dann ist
vorbei und dann schmeckt es total bitter
und ihr könnt es nicht mehr da hätten
wir aufpassen und vor allem eine feine
Reibe verwenden und keine grobe und habt
ihr auch so ein komisches Mundgefühl
später wenn ihr da so große Stücke drin
habt und da gebe ich jetzt wie gesagt
auch noch den Saft dieser mittelgroßen
Zitrone mit rein und ganz zum Schluss
noch mehl und Backpulver das müsst ihr
auch nicht sieben das wird einfach
eingerührt kurze bevor ihr mich hier
wäscht in den Kommentaren ich weiß bei
Brownies kommt kein Backpulver mit rein
aber in dem Fall machen wir das einfach
für die Konsistenz ist wir trotzdem eine
Brownie Konsistenz aber wir brauchen das
Backpulver dafür
[Musik]
so der Teig ist fertig mehl und
Backpulver braucht ihr wirklich nur so
kurz wie notwendig unterrühren ich habe
jetzt hier meine eckige Springform ich
schreibe euch die Maße auch mit in die
Infobox und auch alternativ Maße bzw ich
habe ja eine Umrechnungstabelle bei mir
auf der Seite und da könnt ihr dann
einfach ganz bequem umrechnen ich
brauche jetzt für meine Beschichtung
dadurch dass hier auch schon fett mit
drin ist kein Backpapier das heißt gebe
ich es einfach so mit rein Ofen habe ich
vorgeheizt auf 170 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze und dann ist wichtig dass ihr
das halt einmal noch schön glatt
verstreichen und dann wird gebacken
[Musik]
25 Minuten später also wenn ihr die
Stäbchenprobe macht darf es darf jetzt
nicht komplett nass sein aber es darf
ruhig ein bisschen was dran hängen
bleiben soll ja so ein Brownie Charakter
haben so bei mir ist es vollständig
abgekühlt ich habe jetzt hier noch
Puderzucker und da gebe ich Zitronensaft
drauf die einfachste Glasur der Welt
so erstmal noch ein bisschen und wenn
ich merke dass wir die Konsistenz
gefällt dann gebe ich das einfach noch
mal oben drüber und lasse ich das noch
mal so ein bisschen aushärten und dann
könnt ihr direkt servieren ihr könnt das
Ganze übrigens drei Tage lang Essen ist
so saftig und es schmeckt auch am
nächsten Tag noch gut und somit könnt
ihr das auch sehr gut vorbereiten
[Musik]
geht immer Leute also was soll ich sagen
alle lieben Zitronenkuchen alle lieben
Zitronen Brownies ich muss sagen wenn
man den jetzt vergleicht mit meinem
Zitronenkuchen Rezept da sind so ein
paar Feinheiten die ein bisschen anders
sind das hier ist im Vergleich ein
bisschen klitschiger und das andere ist
ein bisschen luftiger je nachdem was ihr
bevorzugt könnt ihr euch dann ein Rezept
aussuchen ich feiere das übelst und ich
finde es auch cool dass ich dir jetzt
hier so in kleinere Häppchen aufgeteilt
habe so könnt ihr das dann zum
Geburtstag mitnehmen beim Grillen
irgendwie als Snack ähm danach mega
feier ich macht's unbedingt nach und
abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos wenn
ihr solche Rezepte nicht mehr verpassen
möchtet und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss